[Musique]
ce n'est pas un isolement choisi mais
imposer comme ça du jour au lendemain
donc forcément quelque chose va va
manquer forcément ça va être plus
compliqué les conseils qu'on peut donner
c'est un peu de bon sens
évidemment c'est continuer les liens par
tous les moyens de communication
modernes que nous possédons voilà que ce
soit les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
téléphone que ce soit pas tout skype
éventuellement pour que les personnes
puissent poursuivre les contacts
indispensables pour elle et puis celles
qui vivaient plus seul bien peut-être
elles vont moins en souffrir mais il ya
aussi à s'interroger est-ce que c'est
suffisant peut-être cette période peut
permettre de se poser des questions pour
la presse
[Musique]
ça dépend ça dépend si vous étiez bien
si vous n'étiez pas bien ça dépend de
plein de choses donc pour ces raisons là
on part on va préconiser aux personnes
qui vivent en couple de quand même faire
attention parce que la température
risque de monter très vite et si c'est
trop électrique ça risque de basculer
dans quelque chose de très grave voire
d'irrémédiable on sait que dans les huis
clos les violences explosent
que ce soit des petites violences d
énervement ou des très graves violences
par exemple en chine on a découvert que
après l' isolement
eh bien il ya eu énormément de divorce
donc voilà je crois qu'il faut se
préserver des temps des temps seuls des
temps où on n'est pas l'un sur l'autre
si l'appartement ou la maison le propre
le permet c'est formidable
si c'est très petit il faut sortir l'un
après l'autre pour que chacun ait un peu
de respiration et si le couple va mal il
faut faire extrêmement attention de pas
trop s'abîmer l'un l'autre
[Musique]
tout ce qui vient d'être dit doit être
mis en place et on va ajouter le fait
qu'on va être plusieurs
donc les temps de respiration absolument
indispensable on n'est pas obligé de
prendre tous nos repas ensemble on peut
décider que seuls le dîner doit être
pris en commun
le reste du temps est bien un des deux
parents avec les enfants va travailler
sortir faire un jeu de société s'amuser
regarder quelque chose un film on n'est
pas obligé d'être les uns sur les autres
et se bouffer l'oxygène c'est vraiment
très important c'est pas le temps que ça
va durer donc cette incertitude fait qu'
on doit penser à durer durer que ça
puisse être sympa par ailleurs les ados
c'est quand même une population
particulière faut pas que les parents
souhaitent de bonheur qu'ils fassent
comme si il faut leur laisser un espace
de liberté qu'ils puissent communiquer
avec leurs copains leurs copines médias
qui est qu'ils puissent avoir leur vie
sociale de leur côté sinon ça va être
vraiment la cocotte minute et ça va être
atroce or c'est pas ça le but du
confinement
[Musique]
sur mon blog j'ai ouvert dès aujourd'hui
la possibilité de consultation par
téléphone bien sûr obligatoirement
circonstance exceptionnelle réponse
exceptionnelle et aussi chaque jour je
mettrais un blog chaque jour parce que
je pense que oui la solitude
l'enfermement ça réveille une insécurité
profonde et ça il faut pas l'ignorer
faut faire avec parce que ça existe